have you ever wondered what
dinosaurs were afraid of
what creature in the cretaceous period
made
taking a drink of water a dangerous
gamble
i'm talking about terror crocs
no no no not not those crocs dino
sukis otherwise known as
the terror crocodile
what made terror crocs such extreme
predators
[Applause]
if they were still around what would
threaten their survival today
and were they able to eat dinosaurs
bones and all this
is what if and here's what would happen
if
terror crocs were still alive
about 80 to 73 million years ago
dinosukis ruled over the marshes and
swamps
and feasted on unsuspecting dinosaurs
fossils have been found showing that
terror crocs grew
up to 10 meters long and they likely
weighed
close to 5 tons just about the size
of a city bus they had banana sized
teeth
and jaws powerful enough to crush bones
many terror croc fossils have damaged
teeth
leading paleontologists to believe that
terror crocs
chomped on dinosaur bones but
scientists aren't exactly sure if terror
crocs were
hunters or scavengers so
if they happened to roam around today
would they hunt us
[Applause]
this might surprise you but crocodile
attacks
are actually more common than shark
attacks
and they happen around the world
for many people the risk of being
attacked by a crocodile
is a daily concern in fact
thousands of years of crocodile attacks
have contributed to
our evolutionary fear of reptiles known
as herpetophobia
like our fear of spiders we've developed
this phobia over time
it's a natural way that we protect
ourselves like
modern crocodiles the dinosuukis was
more of an
opportunistic predator if anything
happened to come
into its territory these giant crocs
would gobble it up
no questions asked most crocodiles
eat on average 50 meals a year
as ectotherms they gather heat from
their environment so
they don't need to eat as much as some
animals to stay warm
the nile crocodile can eat up to half
its body weight in one meal
if the terror croc ate this much it
could eat about 2
000 kilograms in a day that's
about 36 average sized humans for
breakfast
crocodiles have a unique valve in their
heart
it increases blood flow to their
stomachs through a special aorta
this allows them to secrete gastric acid
10 times faster than most animals
this means that they can dissolve entire
animals
bones and all as terrifying as it would
be to see one of these giants
walking down the street it's more likely
that they would stick to their natural
habitat of marshes
rivers and swamps so you would need to
be
extra careful about where you go fishing
even though terror crocs could wreak
havoc
on our marshland habitats we'd still
hunt them for their skins and make
luxury accessories like handbags shoes
and belts
many crocodiles in africa and parts of
asia
are also killed for their meat
unfortunately
the bigger an animal is the more
attractive it is to trophy hunters
but with conservation efforts around the
world many endangered species of
crocodile
have managed to survive now
if you think terror crocs are scary how
would your life
change if the megalodon still roamed our
oceans
well that's a story for another
what if
you